>> Sean: AS WE CONTINUE WITH
CONGRESSMAN DEVIN NUNES,
CHAIRMAN OF THE HOUSE INTEL
COMMITTEE.
LET ME ASK YOU THIS.
I AM LOOKING AGAIN AT THE MEMO
THAT WAS SENT OUT BY CHUCK
GRASSLEY TODAY, IN OTHER WORDS
THE SECOND MEMO HERE.
I WANT TO REITERATE FOR OUR
AUDIENCE, IT LITERALLY SAYS,
STEELE GATHERED HIS INFORMATION
FROM RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT SOURCES
INSIDE OF RUSSIA.
IT GOES ON TO SAY, MR. STEELE IN
LITIGATION IT APPEARS HE EITHER
LIED TO THE FBI OR TO THE
BRITISH COURTS OR THE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS REVIEWED BY THE
COMMITTEE CONTAINING MATERIALLY
FALSE STATEMENTS.
THEN IT SAYS THAT AS PER THE
TIMELINE IS IMPORTANT ABOUT
JAMES COMEY.
IT SAYS FORMER FBI DIRECTOR IN
JUNE OF 2017 JAMES COMEY
PUBLICLY BEFORE THE SENATE
PRESIDENT-ELECT TRUMP, THIS IS
AT TRUMP TOWER.
TOLD HIM, DESCRIBE THE DOSSIER
SALACIOUS AND UNVERIFIED.
THAT IS LONG AFTER COMEY SIGNED
HE EITHER HANDED TO THE COURT
SOMETHING HE BELIEVED WAS
UNVERIFIED AND SALACIOUS.
OR HE GAVE THE CREDIBILITY WHEN
IT CAUGHT THE INITIAL FISA
WARRANT.
WHICH IS IT?
DO YOU SEE A CONFLICT LIKE I DO?
>> I THINK THE CONFLICT YOU ARE
DESCRIBING, WHICH NO ONE ON THE
LEFT CARES ABOUT OR THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA, IS THAT
POLITICAL DIRT TO OPEN A
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION INTO THE OTHER
CAMPAIGN.
I JUST CAN'T BELIEVE THAT PEOPLE
ON THE OTHER SIDE ARE NOT
I THINK A MAJORITY OF AMERICANS
WILL ULTIMATELY MAKE THE
DETERMINATION THAT USING
POLITICAL DIRT BY THE FBI ON THE
OPPOSING CAMPAIGN IS A PLACE
WHERE WE WANT TO GO.
I WILL TELL YOU.
I THINK MY COLLEAGUES HERE IN
THE HOUSE, THEY ARE FURIOUS
ABOUT THAT THEY'LL MAKE THIS AS
THEY SHOULD BE.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK.
YOU SAID THAT YOU BELIEVE YOUR
INTELLIGENCE AT LEAST 100
>> Laura: WE HAVE HUNDREDS OF
SIDE.
>> Sean: LET'S TALK ABOUT
SARAH CARTER'S ARTICLE TONIGHT.
SHE HAS TWO OF THEM.
AS YOU LOOK AT THIS NEW MEMO
THAT CAME OUT TONIGHT, THE
ALLIES OF THE CLINTON AND OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION WERE PROVIDING
STEELE WITH WHAT THEY DEEM
DAMAGING INFORMATION ON THEN
CANDIDATE TRUMP FOR THAT'S WHAT
WE GET INTO SIDNEY BLUMENTHAL
AND OTHER CLINTON ASSOCIATES.
LET ME SEE IF I'M UNDERSTANDING
THIS CORRECTLY.
IS IT POSSIBLE, SIR, THAT
CLINTON ASSOCIATES WHERE FEEDING
INFORMATION TO CHRISTOPHER
STEELE.
I REFER BLACK
I REFER BACK TO ONE REDACTED
PART IN THE MEMO THAT THERE IS
SUBSTANTIAL EVIDENCE THAT
MR. STEELE INTENTIONALLY MISLED
THE FBI ABOUT KEY ASPECTS OF HIS
DOSSIER'S EFFORTS.
IS IT POSSIBLE THAT CLINTON
ASSOCIATES GAVE INFORMATION TO
CHRISTOPHER STEELE THAT WAS THEN
USED FOR SALACIOUS DOSSIER ON
HILARY'S OPPONENT THAT WAS THEN
USED TO LIE TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, OR MISLEAD THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, BECAUSE STEELE LEAKED
ALL OVER TO THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA, AND WAS USED AS THE BASIS
FOR A FISA?
IS THAT POSSIBLE?
SOME OF THE INFORMATION CAME
FROM CLINTON'S OWN PEOPLE?
ANSWER, SEAN, PARTLY WHY THAT IS
REDACTED.
WHATEVER IS THERE IS CLASSIFIED
AND WE CAN GET INTO --
>> Sean: CAN I REDO THE
UNREDACTED PART?
>> WHAT I CAN TELL YOU IS THIS.
WE HAVE AN ACTIVE INVESTIGATION
INTO THE STATE DEPARTMENT.
THAT HAS BEEN ONGOING FOR A
WHILE NOW.
AS SOON AS WE CAN GET THAT
INFORMATION OUT, WE WILL AS THE
INVESTIGATION UNFOLDS.
>> Sean: I HAVEN'T BEEN WRONG
YET, CONGRESSMAN, IN ALL OF THIS
YET, CONGRESSMAN, IN ALL OF THI
IS MY FINAL QUESTION.
LOOK, I CAN KEEP YOU ON THE AIR
FOR THE FULL HOUR.
HOW IS IT POSSIBLE THAT THIS IS
APPARENTLY A KNOWN LIAR WHO HAS
RUSSIAN.
SOURCES, THEN IT'S PAID FOR BY
ONE CAMPAIGN, THAT'S BAD ENOUGH.
SO YOU HAVE RUSSIAN LIES,
PROPAGANDA PAID FOR BY ONE
CANDIDATE.
THEN THAT PAID PROPAGANDA IS
USED FOR A FISA COURT.
THE TOP PEOPLE AT THE FBI AND
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR BY THAT
OTHER CANDIDATE FOR THE VERY
PERSON THEY ARE TRYING TO GET A
SPEECH 24 MEMO ON.
IT'S VERY SCARY.
WE FOUND ABOUT THIS LAST WEEK IN
MARCH.
NOT ALL OF IT.
WE KNEW THE DOSSIER WAS USED IN
SUMS I
TELL MIKE SOME
-- HAVING TO MOVE CLOSE TO GOING
TO CONTEMPT.
IT TOOK SPEAKER RYAN HAVING THEM
THAT THEY WERE BASICALLY GOING
TO BE HELD IN CONTEMPT.
FINALLY, WE ARE TO BREAK LOOSE
ALL THE DOCUMENTATION.
WE ARE ABLE TO GET IT OUT TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE IN THE FORM OF
THE MEMO THAT IS NOW OUT AND
AVAILABLE FOR PEOPLE TO READ.
I THINK PEOPLE SHOULD GO OUT AND
READ THE MEMO.
I REALLY DO.
IF YOUR VIEWERS HAVE NOT READ
THE MEMO, IT IS WORTH YOUR TIME.
I THINK IT WILL BE VERY
ILLUMINATING.
>> Sean: CHAIRMAN NUNES, I
BELIEVE YOU'VE DONE A GREAT
SERVICE.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE NEED TO KNOW
ABOUT ALL OF THIS BECAUSE
FUNDAMENTALLY WE HAD AN EFFORT
TO UNDERMANNED             UNDER
TO UNDERMANNED             UNDEI
TO UNDERMANNED             UNDEE
TO UNDERMANNED             UNDEO
TO UNDERMANNED             UNDER
TO UNDERMANNED             UNDEA
TO UNDERMANNED             UNDED
LAST QUESTION?
>> THERE IS CLEAR EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION.
YOU DON'T GET TO HIRE LAWYERS
AND PRETEND LIKE THAT DIDN'T
HAPPEN.